you don't say squeeze aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur paul hybride aujourd'hui on
va construire des ponts bild
il est vrai on l'a déjà fait mais c'est
un jeu différent d'accord j'ai mal parlé
je m'excuse sa pop up up voilà ça fait
un vrai pont est un peu passé avec son
petit scooter au dessus de l'arrivée à
aucun des choses c'est parti il croit le
[ __ ] il nous donne plus astuce un jeu
c'est idol et nalbandian dans le budget
on est bon on a l'argent des abonnés
pour construire ce pont y est ça passe
ça parce qu'ils y city qu'à hockey ici
c'est parti là c'est très simple il
suffit de construire une petite route
jusqu'à ce point ensuite ça leur lit là
qu'on relit la up et là on peut y aller
voilà mais c'est toujours pareil
regarder en la la c'est pour les enfants
ce juste pas pour les ingénieurs au pont
comme moi voilà ça tient je suis sûre
battant
tu brito dagas la hanche a besoin d'être
la pire des merdes ok j'ai fait de la
merde oh ça tient mon dieu regardez le
pont dansant peut même
pourquoi t'as pas tenu non mais ça c'est
le hasard ça c'est pourquoi absorbed
faut relier celui-là à celui là où la
petite erreur d'ingénieurs ça arrive ça
arrive c'est encore en étude s'il vous
plaît voilà ça tient
ingénieurs pourront 16 m ouh là là on
commence à faire du pont de qualité
roja était sûr là c'est quoi cette
famille d'obèses plus tard voilà c'est
pire que des [ __ ] de castets ce que
je fais mais ce paraphe j'adore là ça
tient
moi j'aime bien les pros qui bouge un
peu tu vois ça donne un peu de sensation
sauf qu'une famille d'obèses arrive et
cast [ __ ] de ben voilà ça tient
attention accélère et
et je vais attendais pas je suis surpris
mais vraiment alors la folie ce faire
une petite route qui monte finalement
mais a pas grand chose à faire on se
pâme ont spam et c'est parti allez
hockey ni quelle [ __ ] c'était brutal
voilà là ça va tenir je bosse beaucoup
se tient pas une simple route mais
arrête
oui c'est plutôt compliqué france et
drôle n'y avait pas de route c'est parti
pour fair absolument que de la merde
[Musique]
ok
de la merde de qualité aux buts 1 wc
d'actualite tous les points n'importe
comment et ça passe quoi si ça avait été
la même en géométrie ont lieu au lycée
j'aurais adoré malheureusement non ils
demandaient développer et bah moi j'ai
développé couché gros bof ça pique ça
comme là il ya un ascenseur souvient
après les gens être connaissent et ils
disent tu sais lucas dentelle vidéo à 2
minutes 30 tables axes des loisirs j'ai
failli pleurer ça passe
et comment voulez vous que ça tienne à
la fin alors déjà cette musique zen la
base de 1 on boit une tisane tous
ensemble la vie est belle stop à cliquer
vous allez voir il construit un pont en
5 secondes
voilà à ponte totalement dansant
incroyable regarder ce que cet homme
d'affaires il construit un pont en
seulement quatre planches de bois
allez vas-y petit scooter et me fais pas
chier aux attentes
à ça ce repli va baisser pour prendre
moins de place un peu un os ce pont
alors là
et
ça passe tout seul c'est papa dans maman
ça voir job dans luna c'est dégueulasse
non mais toujours plus quoi dans l'excès
ça c'est un jeu d'américains ça c'est ça
qu'ils ont aussi des gros frigo et des
grosses voitures un gros bordel
c'est parti ouais ok by no joe bezannes
annales btrc va jouer à ce joueur avait
classé chanson elle construit des ponts
hockey et ensuite pamela de l'inspirer
l'aller dans son jacuzzi pendant tout
construit des ponts moquette et leurs
fruits comment tu fais
non c'est normal que la vente ont pas ce
que j'attendais
voilà en fait ou dit qu'elle regarde et
là ça tiens ça tient là ça tient à je
sais je sais je suis persuadé l'air
bizarre je suis allé au dessus au lieu
d'aller en dessous j'aime bien les deux
à assas et comme assez comme aux lions
on se sont bâties au furet
watts la vieille manip de merde on est
bloqué au niveau 3 et demie bonjour je
cherche mon diplôme de compteurs voilà
les seules fois où j'ai fait un pont
c'était au lycée qu'on y avait un jour
férié
l'humour drôle
[Musique]
tu pense n'avoir eu jackson et ben non
allez allez allez je te plaît non non
non non non je leur fais encore non non
non non elle et ça va passer je suis pas
borné dans la vie j'écoute chose qu'on
dit non non
[Musique]
pourquoi on est à sa danse de montagne
ça c'est drôle on met à sa dure bord
sondés connaissent je ne comprends pas
mais non mais regardez mais c'est pas
possible ça maintenant je les connais
pas l'épongé construit comme ça
tranquillement chez eux mêmes des devis
gratuits voulait un devis gratuit je
vous en fais je le sens bien
[Musique]
allez allez on arrête les blagues boîte
mais il ya un truc de l'autre côté on
est des énormes merde et vous assumez
avec moi vous me laissez pas passer mais
ça seul bordel
non mais non mais là mais c'est pas vrai
mais ce contrôle avait cédé 8 heures ces
[ __ ] rôle à lui je reconnais son
scooter il a dit cela qu'est il a dit
squeeze je te paie ce
[Musique]
donjon plus loin jean plus dans l'excès
le frigo américain à la grosse voiture
la raquette de tennis alors compris du
badminton voilà
[Musique]
quel soulagement a laissé bon allez pas
un saut de [ __ ] toujours dans l'excès
opus est un bateau qui va arriver des
[Musique]
[ __ ] plaisir était là c'est vrai
c'est fait exprès ça
on a deux brevets de construction de
ponts bogard alors que la petite
technique des triangles qui est vraiment
merveilleuse 1 dans le milieu du pont
les gens l'aiment beaucoup tous les
matins de la vénère et moi tous les
matins je me vénère tout court contre ce
jeu quoi la fin de la blague
effectivement là il faut mettre une
pompe hydraulique
je pense que c'est comme ça
ouais un peu un peut il bien un truc
pour m'aider du shoot yoshi oida
ok je m'attends à venir c'est cool
danger
mais laisse moi avant le temps de lire
[ __ ] ok je prends une photo on en est
là quoi on en est vraiment là sans
déconner je mens cas via un raccourci à
la con voilà voilà la voiture elle passe
hop ça fait ça ça se lève et voilà level
complices allez merci je veux bien
entendre parler de bateaux pont de
bateau il n'y a pas de souci
on attendait six mois puis on fait
toujours un ingénieur dont je réfléchis
tout se pète parfaitement la gueule ne
l'était génie incompris osé genia
compris parce qu'on est con j'en ai
marre pourquoi aujourd'hui je voulais
construire des ponts en plus je viens
juste de me griffer le front là c'était
pour la petite rim avant de re
travailler alors oui oui bien sûr oui ça
sent pas bon voilà je savais déjà à plus
tard
je sais il a une gueule de mer mais ça
va marcher
il a fait quoi on aurait dit d'arrêter
qui venait de mourir sous l'effet du
spray raid
inquiétant mais si les cavs se font un
kiff bon gars tu veux faire quoi aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était samba de janeiro au milieu même
version 28 mai 48 mille dollars le tout
puissant nous met au défi allons-nous
réussir j'ai fait que de la merde pour
soutenir ce pont voilà rien ne va
accorder allemand en tout puissant
oui comme anna
le topic [ __ ] petit bouc a quand même
survécu dans le doute je me suis seul
son monde il faut poser calmement je
vous fais touche là ça tient pas je sais
plus quoi faire je vous le dis
ça pique là ça tient la satire à la
satire là ça tient
[Musique]
au regard des mots quand il fait le
grand écart oh [ __ ] finale j'appelle
tongres en faire autant elle me répond
c'est à dire oui
oui mais voilà les gens s'adaptent à
cette vidéo sur poli bridge pour les
constructeurs j'espère que vous a plus
c'est le cas n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo
comme d'habitude et ben on a notre
brevet de constructeurs de ponts voilà
c'est un grand moment on est diplômé on
peut le dire on se retrouve très bientôt
dans une prochaine vidéo merci d'avoir
regardé portez vous bien un peu de monde
pis
[Musique]